[Applause]
now dave oh this guy is cute what is
this guy it's a little baby wolf
this is a baby wall yeah while you can
you know when you first look at this
thing it kind of looks like a dog but
check out these teeth these teeth are
unbelievable
look at that i mean they could use that
i mean that's what they use for hunting
and they can bring down something as big
as like a water bottle here let's
i'll show you what he can do okay here
we'll bring this food out right here
okay
and watch how fast he eats this oh my
god i mean that amazing now this guy
eats
all the time what happens if you try and
take the food away well see
that's it see whenever you go for their
food
they're very pretty see that's what
they're they're very kind of brother
like this you know what you know why
they like that i'm like give me that big
mac
it's so wild you know why they're white
because they live in packs so they have
they're always competing with each other
and like the biggest wolves always get
the food first and then the smaller
wolves always have to like scramble
around for the um
for the other ones so we should let them
happen see isn't that amazing
it is what's funny is they they live in
such so
can i just have a little bit i was
wondering if i could just tap do you
think i could just maybe have
oh you're always good he's right maybe
he got okay no he's fine
now how long before this guy becomes a
killer actually he's four months now so
he'll be a killer probably by the end of
the year i mean they get about 120
pounds
this is an animal that could like i said
a whole pack of them can take down
something as big as a buffalo but that's
with rifles if they have rice
yeah it's amazing i really think he's
cute though it's descendant well
take it easy
soothing he's desperate he's such a
sweetie he's a sweetie isn't he's
amazing i'm gonna give him a back rub
that'll calm him oh that'll definitely
if more animals in the wild got swedish
back massage and neck massage there'd be
very bad creatures
yeah we should work on that all right
let's keep moving we've got a lot of
animals to put this guy down thanks nick
do you even know that guy
uh yeah well yeah someone just ran in
here now these guys are great this is
another north american animal these guys
are just babies
these are so neat these are prairie dogs
are they cute they're really
that's so great they have the reaction
that half my guests have of like
what
but so far they called prairie dogs well
these are the ones that live in big
families too like a wolf they're all so
i want to make the same sound uh start
barking at them because they bark just
like a regular dog
yeah he's wagging his tail he likes it
here if you go up real close they kiss
each other in the wild too so all right
that's not our business that's what they
did
all right oh oh god hey buddy let's keep
moving let's get some more in here
hey little fella hi little buddy who are
these
these are people from the ladies and
these are people from the audience
coming out
[Applause]
these are from south america these are
little armadillos oh my god you know we
have
we have armadillos right in florida and
texas let's just let people drink in the
visual baby
these are uh these what are you doing
well just feeding these these are dog
food too so you can just
write like that you're a pig what are
you doing well they like it you know
what's so funny about armadillos yeah
they clearly love it
even the armadillos were like he used
his hand dude
what's his problem look at that they
don't have any teeth they just use their
tongue just like an annie they're in the
same family as like an anteater or
any of those yeah these are they have
like weird claws and then if they are
threatened by say a talk show host do
they turn up into a ball like
i'll get you well that one's the female
there hear that look how he yeah this is
the male here and the male can ah
they're all here put your finger yeah
just feel the fur right there it's
amazing yeah but look at that i mean
they can close completely up
and how do you know the male from the
female well the male actually what's so
funny because armadillos you'd figure it
would be difficult for them to mate so
the male actually has a five-inch penis
that he can work underneath the female
so it's unbelievable i mean
so it's like in proportion and
proportion armadillos have
five inches is good anywhere
in proportion yeah well because he's so
smart
hello oh sure here thanks maria uh send
these guys a little shot but look at
that i mean those
they can dig so quickly and then they
look like rocks and then so they become
like
actual little round rocks if they're in
danger exactly and they're
what happens too is that they oh thanks
sabrina what happens to is like if
something like a jaguar or someone would
bite and they can't break that show it's
totally protected so they're just in
there like reading the paper until the
hey i'm talking look at that i know that
love
you're definitely watching now i know
this from eating cereal this is a toucan
seriously that's how i know it
and quite frankly if more uh sugar
cereals had animals on the cover i would
know
more about animals oh yeah definitely
what's so funny and they got that so now
they're synonymous
he wants you to shut up i think he just
wants me to feed him here give him this
what do i do well what's so neat even
though they look pretty clumsy with the
speak they're very dexterous with it so
if you throw something he can catch it
just like
if i throw a grape you can catch it i'll
get him way over here hey buddy hold it
stop talking over here
okay ready
so how did he do at the dmv i'm just
curious
okay again try it again hey buddy come
on you're talking about huh uh
uh ready uh uh uh
oh my god
[Applause]
buddy right here right here right here
huh
you have another grape yeah i got an
idea okay
that's how you catch a grape all right
we're going to take a break jared miller
everybody
margaret chose coming up we'll be right
back stick around